okay Donald Trump's desperation has
escalated by orders of magnitude
probably in the last 15 minutes but
generally speaking over the last couple
of weeks and yesterday at a rally in
Jackson Mississippi the Republican
presidential nominee called Hillary
Clinton a bigot saying she would do
nothing for african-americans and
Hispanics we have the video let's take a
look Hillary Clinton is a bigot who sees
people of color only his votes not as
human beings worthy of a better future
she's going to do nothing for
african-americans she's going to do
nothing for the Hispanics the Hispanic
only gonna take care of herself her
husband her consultants her donors these
are the people she care about right so
the the amazing thing is Trump is known
for going wildly off script danna Bash
from CNN said that the reference to
Hillary's bigotry was actually on the
teleprompter although reportedly the
teleprompter said Hillary Clinton's
bigoted policies not she is a bigot I
actually think Rachel that Trump should
be worried about admitting to his
supporters that Hillary Clinton won't do
anything for blacks or Hispanics because
if they believe it that might appeal to
them and they might say hey I'm in a
vote for Hillary she's not gonna do
anything for blacks and Hispanics it's
dangerous in that way right that'd be a
great tactic for him but no matter what
he's saying he is still the bigot
because he has eight percent of the
black vote yet he's not convinced voters
that actually Hillary Clinton is the
bigot because he's actually polling a
zero percent among black voters in some
states and nationally somewhere between
six and eight percent for people who
were watching today some of the people
on stage behind Trump were shocked
confused and some actually entertained
when Donald Trump called Hillary Clinton
a bigot let's start first with this one
woman who her first reaction is as sort
of looking like shock will get back to
her here's another person who reacted by
laughing hysterically the guy with the
huge pin
no what kind of pin that is but as we
know the bigger the pin on your suit the
more patriotic you are uh next person
who had an interesting reaction is this
guy in the white beard who was he threw
his head back in laughter when Trump
called Hillary Clinton a bigot the next
picture I have for you is going back to
that first woman whose look has gone
from sort of surprise to absolute horror
and then I think we have one more here
which is this woman behind Trump who is
just cringing that is sort of i would
describe that as a grimace wouldn't you
Louis yeah but it also could be a laugh
and both are acceptable when Donald
Trump says something like that Breitbart
news CEO Steve Bannon is now co campaign
manager for Donald Trump's I don't think
it's any surprise that he's going to
this and the the crazy thing is the
right claims to take really seriously
accusations of racism and bigotry they
always say Oh liberals are just so loose
by calling everybody racist calling
everybody a bigot and that seems to be
exactly what Trump is doing isn't it I
mean what else oh they have to lose
right that's become the mantra of the
Trump campaign now I feel like what what
does he have to lose at this point uh
and uh he he's turning everything around
on Hillary Clinton apparently tonight at
a speech Trump is going to accuse
Hillary Clinton of wearing a bad toupee
having an unnatural orange suntan and
also having really small hands I mean
why stop at calling her a bigot right
right yeah it's uh yeah I guess this is
the logical next step in Trump's attacks
and the normal stuff the Benghazi stuff
the the health stuff to conventional yes
you gotta kick it up a notch now I've
talked about how people of all ages but
particularly Millennials are owning cars
less and participating more in the
sharing economy and one of the more
popular options is zip car which gets
you a car when you want it when you need
it they offer all sorts of cars SUVs
hybrids whatever you need it includes
insurance and it includes gas you just
pay for the time that you actually use
the car and you can reserve the car
online from your smartphone over the
phone then you unlock it with your
zipcard each car share member reduces
their personal co2
shins by between 1100 and 1,600 pounds
per year for our audience zipcar is
offering $25 a free driving credit if
you sign up at joined zipcar dot-com /
David support our show reduce your
carbon emissions and you're spending on
cars sign up at join zipcar dot-com /
David